サッブパパッサアカラナン クサラッサウパサンパダ
サチッッタパリヨーダパナン エータンブッダナサーサナン
では よろしくお願いします
えーと 雨の中 本当にありがとうございます
えっと 結構今日来られない方々もいらっしゃるので
皆様それよく覚えてないようね
お友達に教えてあげてください
えーと まあ今日のテーマはまあ私が悪いの？という
ちょっとなんか変なテーマなんですけどね
で これあの 疑うべき常識というのは真面目なテーマなんです
ふざけたテーマと真面目なテーマで
どうしてもふざけたテーマをつけないとね
なかなかみんな興味持たないんですからね
えっと 次に行きましょう
で 私は正しい 間違い...間違い
間違うはずはありません
という体感でいきます
それで今日私の話の内容はこの私たちの認識って信頼できるのかと
私が知ってること 本当に信頼できるのかっていうところを分析していきたいと思いますね
で 私たちはこの建前では認めないんですけどね
心の本音は私は正しいという本音なんです
私には私は間違うはずはないんだと
はい これでこの私は正しいという風にこの言わないんですよ
誰も 言わないんだけど
日常生き方を見ると みんな自分が正しいということで
すごいしつこくしがみついて生きてるんです
いくら問題が起きても
いくら悩み苦しみが起きても
全然気にしない 自分が正しいというスタンスで生きているんです
だから世の中トラブルだらけなんですね
全く調和 平和 何もないんです
で その理由はいたって簡単
私は正しい その問題なんですね
これはなかなか気づかないんですね
ですから この私は正しいというこの錯覚がね
なんで錯覚かというと
建前で言わないでしょ
建前で言わないとは まあ自分知ってますね
世界は認めてないんだと
自分の意見は ですから
これ錯覚はどのように生まれるものかと
で これからさっさと早く飛ばしながら理解していきましょう
まず この知るという働きは何なのかと
これからちょっと仏教専門用語を使いますけどね
これは話を短くするためなんです
眼耳鼻舌身意という感覚器官に色声香味触法という情報が流れます
まあすぐ理解してください
我々にはこの認識する器官が 6つありますね
眼耳鼻舌身意というんですね
その感覚器官に何か触れるんですね
その触れるものには仏教用語で色声香味触法というんですね
まあまあ よく何回も話を聞いてる方々は知ってると思います
目に触れるデータに仏教用語で色というんですね
耳に触れるデータに仏教用語でまあ声ですね
声 音というんですね まあ声という漢字書いてますけど
本当は音なんですね で
鼻に触れるデータに香りというし
舌に触れるデータに味というし
で 体に触れるデータには感触ですね
触れるだけですね それは
それから心に触れるデータ
心に何か触れますかね
触れます まあ概念と理解してください
心に触れるデータには法というんですね
まあ法っていうのは仏法の法ではなくて
ものごとって意味なんですね
これで認識が起こるんですね
知るということは情報が触れたことを感じるんです
その体に何か 例えば音が入っちゃうと
手足ではなくて耳で感じるんですね
見えるものは目で感じるんですね
この感じることをすごくよく気をつけてください
それからそれを合成して知識にします
この感じたもの データではないんです
当たり前なんです データを感じたんだから
感じた範囲で頭の中で合成するんですね
組み立てるんです これ
組み立てるもの 建てたものに知識というんです
だから音があっても 皆様の耳に同じく触れるわけじゃなくて
皆様の耳がどの程度で感じるのかということで
話を聞いたということになるんですね
音を聞いたということで
だからそこから問題が起こるんですよ
結局は私たちは世の中のことを知っているんだといっても
あなたの六根の力次第やということになるんです
それはいくら科学的な科学使っても同じことなんですね
望遠鏡やら顕微鏡やら電子顕微鏡やらね
宇宙望遠鏡やら こんなのは何使ったっても
知るのは自分の一般的に五感というんですけど
仏教用語使いますので六感ですね
この六感の能力次第です
同じ情報が触れても 各個人の知識は同じではありません
ですから 同じデータが触れても
各個人の知識はそれぞれ違います
それは主観というんですね
サブジェクティブ主観です
ということは何ですかね
これ大胆な話ですよ 知識とは主観です
皆様の場合はね 科学的なものとかね
まあ数学とかは主観ではないでしょうと思うかもしれませんが
仏教的にはそれも主観なんです
結局は はい 主観の本質
まず孤独 一人一人の自分の主観があります
人間に限ったものではなく
一切の生命も 各自の主観を持っているんです
ちょっと哲学者になってみてください
一人一人に自分の主観があるんです
これは人間に限ってないんです
どんな生命にも 神々にも
お化けにも お化けいるかどうかよくわかりませんだけどね
生命である限り 自分の主観というものはあるんです
他人の主観を知りえないんです
これ主観だからね 他人がどういうふうに
例えば私に皆様は見えますけど
皆様に私にどのように見えるかと知ることは一切不可能です
私は喋ってる声が私にも聞こえますけど
私にとっては皆様にどのように聞こえているのかを知ることが一切不可能です
たとえ皆様方座っているところに私が座ってみても
それは私の耳で聞いたものなんです
隣の人にどう聞こえるかわからないんです
ということで また哲学者になってください
他人の主観は知り得ないということ
たとえ知ったとしても
それは他人の主観に対する自分の主観です
例えばお母さんが今日は子供がなんかちょっと落ち込んでるなとかね
言っても 子供がどのように落ち込んでいるかとお母さんがわからないんです
それはお母さんの主観なんです
だからお母さんが子供の気持ちをわかっているんだという調子に乗ってますけど
それはお母さんの主観であって
だからトラブル起こるでしょ
時々 家族の中でも ですから
コミュニケーションが成り立たないので
生命は本来孤独です これが大きな問題です
生命は孤独です 自分一人だけの世界に生きているんです
気づかないんです それには
気づかないんだから 人のことよくわかってますよと
世の中のことよくわかってます
えらい迷惑でしょ ああいう人々は
特にこの知ったかぶりする人々ほど社会迷惑
あるいはもう迷惑というか汚染なんですね
で そうなるんですね はい
次のテーマに行きます
また本質出てきます 主観を作る目的理解しましょう
なんで私は私の世界だけ作り
そこに閉じ込まれて世界知らずでいるんですかね
なんでそんな間違ってることで
話聞いてなんか変でしょ？なんであんな変なことやってますかね
死にたくはない 生き続けたいという気持ちを支えるために自分の世界を作るんです
生命は死にたくないんです
生きていきたいんです
そのために物事を知ろうとしているんです
どんな立派な人間であっても
皆様であっても 私であっても
ものを知る場合は自分が生きていきたいから
死にたくないんだから
その 目的で 物事を知ったり
聞いたり 味わったり 考えたりする
存在欲と恐怖ですね それは
生きるとはどのようなものかと調べず
結論に達しているんです
その状態は無知あるいは無明というんです
はい 生きていきたいと思うのは一向に構いませんよ
そう思うために調べて結論してほしいんです
こういうわけで生きていきたいんだと
こういうわけで命に価値があるんだと
生きる意味があるんだと
これ調べてないんです
赤ちゃんも犬も猫も野生の鳥たちも生きていきたいんです
調べてないでしょ 何も調べてない
生きるとは何か まるっきりわからない
それで生きていきたいというんだから
仏教はそれは無明 無知というんですね
だから無明無知はもう everyone みんなにあるんです
輪廻転生する一切の生命にあるんです
皆様方をお祈りする神々
神々にも無明があるんです
そこで生きていきたいということと
死にたくないという恐怖感
で 頑張るんですね そのために物事を知らなくちゃいかんですね
要するに 貪瞋痴が主観を作るんです
また 仏教用語で言えば貪瞋痴が主観を作るんです
はい これで生きていることの仏教の答え
感じるなら生きている
生きているという実感が感覚から起こるのです
感覚がなくなることは死です
すごいシンプルなことなんです
みんななんか変で それ認めたくないんです
魂があるんじゃない 命があるんじゃないと思っちゃうんです
だからお釈迦様は科学者なんです
ものすごい精密に怖い科学者なんです
だからドキャンと言うんですね
で お釈迦様の言葉で言えば
もうあなた何かいろんな感じるでしょ？滅込んで
この感じることが生きることやと
なんかえらいシンプルですよ
命の定義は 感じるかないか
例えばこのスポンジは生きてますか？生き物ではない
もしかするとね なぜならば
スポンジには感覚がありません
それもやはりもしかするとなんですね
スポンジが感じるかどうか知る方法がないんだからね
それは人間の主観で知りますよ
例えば私は感じるから反応する
誰が私の体を触ったら
何ですか？と聞く スポンジはこうやってねじっても反応しない
だから感覚ないだろうと人間である私は思うんです
だからわからないんですよ
これも生き物かどうか
でも一応生き物ではありません
だから生き物かないか知る方法っていうのは
感覚があるかないか 感覚があるかないかっていうことは反応するんだからね
よくわかりますよ それ
感覚がなくなったら死んでるんです
そうするとスポンジと同じく私たちは物体になるんです
ありがたい体だと思っているんだけど
燃やしちゃいます 全部
物体だから 感覚があるならば燃えませんよ
生きているんだから 絶えず色相こう民族という情報が五感を刺激して感覚を作る
それで五感 目耳鼻という ５つ
それにはデータが触れるわ
触れるわ 触れるわ 触れる
キリがないでしょ 目が開いている限り見えるわ
見えるわ 見えるわ 目は閉じることできるんだけど
耳なんかは閉じることもできない
だから音があるならば聞こえるは聞こえるは
それよりも音があると聞こえる
ないと聞こえないんだけど
肉体どうですかね スーッと感じているんです
皆様は座っていらっしゃるんだからね
スーッと座っていることを感じているんです
手足をスーッと感じているんです
肉体全体的にスーッと感じているんです
その感覚は消えることはないんです
まあ熟睡するときは体があるかどうかよくわからないんですね
もしかするとその時 体
体の感覚はないかも しかし
チャネルは開いているんです
だから人が寝ていても触って揺すったら起きるんですね
だから体という窓を閉めてないんです
窓を開けてるんだけど
この感じる機能がちょっと
椅子から離れているんです
机からそれだけ というと
なんか実体論で考えますけど
まあ一旦その機能はまあ休んでいるような感じで
それは誰かが触っちゃうとすぐ目が覚めますね
ということは 我々は生きてない瞬間はなかなかないんです
データ触れることで生きているんです
データ触れると感じる
データ触れなかったら感じない
音があるならば耳で感じる
そういうことですから
音がない時 我々死にますかね？死なないんですね
見えるものない 例えば目隠しをする
それで死ぬんですかと言えばそうじゃないんです
なぜならば 何かしらずっと感じているんです
過去 現在 未来 あるもの
ないもの あってほしいもの
欲しくないものなどの概念に触れて
意識が働いて感覚を作る
それは思考妄想ということですね
どうですかね 感覚がない瞬間ないんです
時に我々にわからないのは
この六根で意はなんなのかとね
意っていうのはもう皆様知っているのは考えることだけなんですね
だから考えるところですね
考えるために何か触れなきゃ
何か対象がなければ考えられないんですね
どういう対象かというと
過去のこと 将来のこと
今のこと あること ないこと
あってほしいこと あってほしくないこと
あれやこれやと頭で考えている
面白いことは 五感には現実的なデータ触れなきゃできないんです
意味はデータが現実であっても
架空なものであっても大丈夫です
いわゆる意で存在しないものさえ感じるんです
これで結構世の中はハチャメチャになっているんです
だって神々を作るわ あれやこれやとかね
天国作るわ 人殺したら天国に行けるんだとへっちゃらで言うわ
そういう人々は真面目に信じてるんです
テロ行為をやれば天国に行けるんだと
このシステムは停止しないので問題なく生き続けられますよ
なぜ停止しないんだから
感覚は 触れるわ 触れるわ
触れるわ いくらでも触れる
だから触れるデータはありすぎ
節約する必要はないんです
体にデータがなくなったっても
意識が 架空のものでも考えているんです
ということは 論理的に考えれば
嫌ででも生命は生きられるんです
それストップできるもの働きではないんです
しかし 全て無常なので生命は死ぬ
この場合は この肉体がある形の肉体が壊れていくんだというだけの話で
論理的に考えると 五感六感にデータが限りなく触れる
これはいくらでも触れる
ノンストップで停止なくということは
人は死にたくないと思う必要もないんです
生きていきたいと思う必要はないんだ
あれは無駄な無駄です
あんなのは 生きていきたい
生きていきたい 思わなくても
思ったってもどうしたことはないんです
生きられること ストップできないんです
そこで我々人間が知りたくないというのは
この肉体 これは壊れるのは嫌だけの話なんです
しかし 物質は無常ですし
情報も無常でしょうし
だからまあ 形は壊れます
壊れたんだからってそこで終わったかというと終わってないんです
例えば我々は 例えば花火を見ている
見えてますね 感覚が起こる
それで花火はすぐ消えますね
どうなる？消えたこと見えているのは
だからものは無常であっても
まあ感覚がもう一緒に変化して続くんです
意識はこの事実を否定するので概念に触れ続けるのです
それで 我々の意識はこの架空の物でも認識する
存在しないものでも認識する
意識はね 肉体を壊れることは嫌なんです
そうすると肉体が壊れても意識は自分で頑張るんです
次から次へとデータ触れるんです
だからこの私はちょっと輪廻転生のことを説明したいんですけど
これは輪廻転生ということになります
非科学的な概念というわけじゃなくて
精密で科学的な概念なんです
輪廻転生っていうのは
科学者がわからないんだからといって知ったことじゃありません
皆様にも私にはわかりませんって知ったことはありません
仏教はものすごい優れた精密な科学なんです
これ六根に分けているんです
六根にデータが触れて感覚が生まれるところを知っているんです
だから仏教では命という
なんていうか なんて言いますか
個体したものはないんです
六種類の感覚が生まれては消え
生まれては消え 生まれては消え
だから私というのはただの単語で
ここで六種類の流れがあるんです
それの中で意識という流れがね
肉体の滅びることは認めませんし
自分では認識し続けるんです
だって意識には現実的なデータなくていいんだから
それはどうなるかというと
例えば肉体が滅びちゃう
壊れる 壊れても意識が次の次の次のこと認識して変化するんです
はい そこで渇愛という仏教用語を紹介します
認識し続けたい 感じ続けたいという気持ちは渇愛
タンハというんですね
だから一般仏教では渇愛っていうのはね
食べたい 遊びたい 寝たいとかね
金儲けたいという程度だと思ってるでしょ
それじゃないんです もっと精密なところで
これは認識し続けたいんです
それが渇愛なんです 微妙なんです
美味しいものを食べたいっていうことは
これ欲でしょうと自分ではわかってるんだからね
そんな程度じゃないんです
金持ちになりたい なりたいと渇愛
欲があっても 話し合えばわかる
まあね やめなさい そんなのはと
面倒くさいんだからね
ああ そうね じゃあ金持ちになることやめますという気持ちになることはできますよ
でもその人は渇愛なくなっているかというと
そうじゃないんです だから認識続けたいという気持ちが渇愛ですね
この渇愛は三つに分けられます
1 カーマタンナ 五欲 前も五欲という単語を丸括弧に入れましたからね
いわゆる五感にデータ触れてほしい
これも一般仏教では五欲っていうのはね
美しいものを見て 美味しいものを食べて
美しい音楽を聴いて楽しむことやと思ってますけどね
本当はそうじゃないんです
精密な意味は 五感が感じ続けたいだけ
2番目 バヴァタンナ それは存在欲というわけですね
3番目 ヴィバヴァタンナ
非存在欲 いろんなものをなくしてほしいという気持ちもある
まあ嫌だ これはとかね
例えば人生でね もううまくいかなくなっちゃって
もうもう絶望で絶望でね
失望で もう全くもう明かりがない場合は死にたいでしょ
それも渇愛なんです 死にたいとも同じ感じたいってことなんです
渇愛がある限り主観を作り続けるんです
そこで我々には渇愛がありまして
認識続けたいという だからずっと主観を作るんです
知ることですね 知識 認識の狙いは何ですかね
次 なんで認識するんですかね？なんで我々に知識があるんですかね
知識の狙いは 面白いことに物事を知ることではありません
私は事実を知りたい 本当のことを知りたい
だから知識を欲しい あれは嘘です
もしそうであるならば
主観はまずいんです もし私たちが事実知りたければ
本当のことを知りたければ
主観ってまずいでしょう
認識することで貪瞋痴
3つの渇愛に燃料をあげて壮大するんです
だから我々はなんで知識が欲しいと思うかというと
なんで物事を認識するのかと
だからこれ 3つです システム
知ること 認識すること
あ 知る知識 認識なんですね
で もしかすると知識は 3番目かもしれませんだけどね
もうちょっと固めたんですね
まずなんとなく知る なんとなく知ったものははっきりどういうことかと知る
それは認識ですね それからそれについて知識を作る
それで我々は貪瞋痴を壮大するんです
認識は知るためではなく
生きるためです なんで認識するのか
なんで知識があるのかというと
それは生きるためなんです
それの方がわかりやすいと思いますね
貪瞋痴の話よりも 生きるためにやっているんです
生きていきたいのは私でしょ
それで情報をネッソするんです
私は生き続けたい だから認識
感覚をし続けます それで触れたデータを生きることを支えてくれるもの
生きることに邪魔をするもの
関係ないものという 3つに分けてネッソします
六根に入るデータを 3つに分けるんです
分けてますよ みんな  一つ命を支えてくれるもの
一つ邪魔なもの もう一つは関係ないもの
支えるものに愛着 可愛い
美しい 美味しいなどの感情を作るんです
命を支えるものに対しては愛着が生まれるんです
可愛いと思うんです 美味しいと思うんです
美しいと思うんです で
邪魔する者に嫌なもの
敵 ライバル 危険 迷惑 駆除するべきもの
壊す 殺すべきもの あるいは汚い
醜いなどの感情を作るんです
理論だけだからちょっとわかりにくいかもしれませんだけどね
この 2つに入らないものに対して無関心
調べる必要はない 認識するに値しないなどの無知の感情を作るんです
これが主観の中身です
主観の中身っていうのは
例えば私はなんでしたっけ？アボカドをすごく美味しい好きと思う
皆様方はアボカドなんかなんだあれはと
それよりはキウイフルーツの方が美味しいと思うかもしれませんね
それは主観です なぜならば
アボカドを食べると私は美味しくて
なんか存在の味見方やと思っちゃうんですね
私の命を助けて支えてくれるんだと
だから音の場合もね あれってうわー綺麗な音楽ですねとかいうのは
自分がいい気分になって自分の命を支えているんです
そこで汚いっていうものは敵ですね
醜いっていうのは 自分の命を支えてくれないと思うものなんですね
それで私は正しい ご飯は美味しい
草はまずい 猫は可愛い
蛇は気持ち悪い 音楽は好き
数学は嫌いという もうちょっとした例なんですね
これは主観です 自分を支えるものとそうでないものです
ご飯は美味しいとなんで思う？肉体を支えてくれるんだから
なんで草はまずいと思う？食べても肉体は支えてくれない
だから問題は本当にご飯が美味しいなのか
草はまずいなのかっていうことなんで
客観的に見ると草は美味しそうに食べる生命がいるんです
我々人間は草は 食べ物だとも思わないんですね
だからそれ習慣でしょ
自分の存在のために認識したんですね
それで私はご飯がとても美味しいものですよと
それは事実だよと思っても
それは猫は食べませんね
ヤギさんも食べませんね
ライオン トラも食べませんでしょ
その生命体にはまずいんです
ね 醤油やら砂糖やらいろんなみりんやら
もうあれぐらいもう強烈に味付けちゃってね
動物はまずいぞ そんなのはと思いますよ
これって間違っていると言える？ってハテナです
ご飯は美味しい 間違っている？花はきれい
間違っている？間違っていると思ってないでしょ
だから私は正しいんです
そういうスタンスが成り立つんです
ちょっと考えれば ご飯は美味しいと思うのは人間だけで
腐った肉でももう死骸
腐ってる人 生命 動物の死骸でも
ハイエナとかすごく美味しそうに食べてるんですね
だからハイエナにとっては
もう動物の死骸がいくら時間経って腐っていても
骨だけであっても美味しいんです
ハイエナの顎が強いんだからね
骨ジャリジャリとかじって食べるんです
だからハイエナは自分を正しいと思っている
ご飯を食べている私たちと
私たちは正しいと思っている
したがって 自分は正しいんです
次 はてな先に入れた 間違った判断はできませんと
これもちょっと心のカラクリなんですよ
大好物のケーキは美味しくないと思えない
これは個人差がありますよ
例えば ある人がケーキが好物
ケーキの中でもいろんな種類がありますから
まあ私はあまり種類はわかりませんだけど
まあ例えばチョコレートケーキにしましょう
ある人はチョコレートケーキ好きで好きでたまらない
それでその人にお願いする
あのね お願いしますから
一回だけで十分だからね
チョコレートケーキまずいと感じてもらう
もらえる？できる？できないんです
これは不可能です 例えば
花を見る あ きれいな花ですと
ちょっと待ってください
一回だけで十分だから
この花は醜い 汚いと見てください
感じてください 口で言ったって意味がないんです
本当に感じてほしい  汚い花ですねとかね
ああ 気持ち悪いと思える？思えないんです
そこまで言うならば そうそうそう
まあ汚いですね この花は
と言うかもしれません
あれは嘘 よく調べてみてください
鳥たちが美味しそうに食べる昆虫を自分にも美味しいと思うことはできません
鳥たちがね パクパクと昆虫を取って食べてると
ああ 美味しいな 俺も食いたいなと思える？思える？思えないんです
それは人間にとって間違った判断なんです
人間もゴキブリやらいろんな昆虫を食べることになっちゃうと
ちょっと困ったことで
だからまあそう思わないんですね
我々の認識構造はそうなっているんです
自分が正しい判断をしているということになっているんです
あの人は嫌いと思ったら
それを好きという感情に入れ替えることはできません
例えば 私たちに誰かさんがいて
その人は嫌いですね 自分が
もう嫌いです あ まあ嫌いではなくて
その人のことをすごい好きという気持ちになろうかなと思ったら無理です
赤信号でも渡ってもいいとは思えません
っていうたとえ あんまり合わないたとえ話ですけど
で 無理ですよ 我々は赤信号見たら止まるんです
要するに 我々の判断を変えることはかなり難しい
無理 まあ常識な人間ならね
赤信号とは まあそれはストップという意味ですよと
で 赤信号っていうのはもうゴーという意味ですよって誰も思わないんですね
言ったら もうあんた何言ってるのか
ふざけたことを言うなよと
いうことになるんです
例えばステーキはいいという
そんなのは食べるのかと
気持ち悪いと思える？思えないんです
仏教の世界では 我々はその訓練もするんです
この主観を変える訓練するんです
ステーキは美味しいと思うこともあって
これは死骸やと 死んだ動物の死骸の一部だと思うことをします
そうすると別な気持ちになるんです
花は必ず 花は綺麗に決まっているというふうに
我々宗教はそう思わないんです
そういう まあ認識訓練させている
させるんです 例えば皆様は
まあこの人年寄り この人は子供
この人は女 この人は男とかね
もう勝手な主観で判断するでしょ
我々それをやめる 訓練で
ああ 若い女の人で ああ
なんて可愛いですかと思えないんです
主観は主観を変える訓練しています
だから変える訓練しているんだから
まあ若い女の人で まあ美しい人だっていうこともあって
また別な主観でもスタンスで見ているんです
例えばただの人間で 一つの見方
いえ 無数の生命の中で一人の生命でと
そういうふうに主観を変える訓練するんです
それはその訓練を受けていない方々にとっては
これは無理な話で 花だったら綺麗に決まっている
ご飯だったら美味しいに決まっている
というふうなことになっちゃうんです
いつでも自分の判断は正しいんです
逆できませんだからね
例えば裁判で被告人何かがいて
で 全部この人はこの犯罪を起こしましたと全部証言揃っている
証拠は揃っている 疑いはなし
本人も認める 私がやりましたと
それで裁判官にできますかね
あなたは証拠を揃っているんですが
無罪ですと できませんね
はい 主観の本質 二番に行きます
邪見 主観って大変です
存在欲 生きていきたいを支えるために情報を捏造して主観に陥る
生きていきたいんですよ
だから情報を捏造するんです
死んだネズミをいや 気持ち悪いと言って
同じ死骸 牛の死骸の一部を焼いて出しちゃうと
なんで今日はごちそうだな
豪華だな ステーキでとか
今日は焼き肉食べられて
今日はもう一つありますね
あの なんとかね まあもうあまり食べたことないんですけどね
いろいろ鍋に入れて 肉を入れて取って食べたりする
いろいろ料理あるでしょ
あ すき焼きとかね 今日はすき焼きでごちそうだよとかね
あれって牛の死骸ですけど
牛の死骸ですけど まあ我々は捏造するんですね
美味しいと それですき焼きの鍋にネズミ入れちゃうと大変なことになりますね
そこで私たちはそのようにネズミの死骸は気持ち悪くて大騒ぎするんですが
同じく牛の死骸はなんで美味しいですか？と
豪華だと 今日はごちそうだと喜んで食べている
これは捏造ということなんです
自分の都合によって捏造するんです
主観を守らなくてはいけないんですね
もし皆様方はね あの すき焼き食べてるところ
わしが行って あ あんた方はなんでこの死骸食べてるんですかね？とかね
聞いちゃうと私は変人でしょう
追い出されるでしょうね
だから我々は自分が生きていきたいんだから捏造するんです
捏造したものがあって
それのおかげで生きているんです
だから捏造したデータを守らなくちゃあかんのです
要するに 主観を守らなくてはいけないという罠にはめます
それは本人にとって命を守ることなんです
だから私たちは私たちの知識をしっかり守っているんです
これは命を守っているんです
主観に執着しなくてはいけないんですね
かわいそうで そのために他の情報
真理などを否定したり
攻撃したりしなくてはならないんです
だから私はすき焼き鍋にあるのは牛の死骸やと言うと
皆様は攻撃する 頭がおかしいと
あれやこれやと言うでしょうね
雰囲気を壊す人 まあよくやら頭がいかれているんだというね
いたま簡単に 皆さんもそういう風に言ってますよ
あいつは頭がおかしいと言ってるない
言ってない？自分の主観にと違った主観を持っていると
ああ あの人頭がおかしいと
平気で言うんです ということは
私たちは悪人と言ったっても
この罠にはめられているんです
私はこの肉体を維持するために捏造するデータをして主観を作る
私がそれを守らなくちゃいけなくなっている
はい 主観に執着することは仏教用語でディッティ
ディッティ見解というんです
そういうわけで みんなに見解があるんです
常識的な見解も非常識的な見解もあります
洋食より和食が好むなどはまあ常識範囲です
うなぎはおいしいですと
まあ常識範囲です 玄米ご飯よりは白米ご飯はおいしいですとかね
まあそれはある程度常識範囲です
でも見解は見解です 神を信仰すれば死後永遠の天国だと信じるのは非常識見解です
そういう非常識見解も結構たくさん我々は持っているんです
で 例えばね 大根よりは私はかぼちゃの方が好きですよというのは見解ですけど
まあある程度常識範囲で
それでそんなに大げさな問題は起きません
私は甘いものが大好きだという人は常識範囲ですけど
糖尿病にかかるかもしれませんだけど
まあそれ程度の危険で終わっちゃいます
神様 魂 あるいは永遠の天国
永遠の命とか 何の証拠もない見解を作るんです
それぐらい生きていきたいと思っているんです
存在欲 非常識見解を持つものは直行地獄です
これをお釈迦様が使った単語で
地獄っていうのは不幸に陥ると
死後もう救えません 常識見解の場合は
まあそこでどの程度で心が汚れたということで死後決めますけどね
非常識見解だったらもう
仕方がありません いろいろ非常識見解をお釈迦様時代あったんですよ
因果法則を綺麗に否定する
来世を綺麗に否定する
人間突然この世にで現れたというエクスレターズと言いますけどね
いろいろ 生命とはただの物質ですよと
という科学者もそう思っているしね
そういうのもちょっと非常識見解ですね
はい 次に生き続ける戦いということにいきます
渇愛があるから戦わなくても輪廻転生する
しかし 死にたくはないのに
今の命を守るために必死に努力するんです
だから我々に渇愛あるでしょうし
渇愛あるんだから認識するはするはするは
感じる 感じる 感じる 感じる
絶えず感じているんです
それは心配しなくてもいいんです
なのに我々はやっぱり生きることに戦うんです
それで何に戦うかというと
この肉体を守るためだけなんです
だから犬はその犬の肉体を守るために戦う
猫は猫という肉体を守るために戦う
我々は人間という肉体を守るために戦っているんです
考えてみればいらん戦いなんです
それは 死ぬ心配はないんです
次のポイント 単独では生きられない
生きることは命のネットワークです
他の生命がないと自分だけでは生きられないんです
この命という感覚 感覚というものが
他の生命がいて成り立つんです
生命は無知なので この理解が曖昧です
理解してというのは 曖昧な理解はなんとなくあります
石は食べられないとか
チキンなら食べられるとかね
キャベツなら食べられるとかね
だから肉体を維持するためには
他の生命 命が必要なんですね
味方と敵を作るんですね
それ だって生命と関係あるでしょ
関係あるところで味方
敵 味方 敵に分けるんです
これも主観的な判断なので曖昧です
敵を味方にしたり 味方なのに敵だと思ったりもします
例えば ちょっと大きくなると歳ぐらいになってくると
子供がお母さんを敵だと思っているんですね
敵ではないんだけど そこで悪いことに誘う友達は味方なんです
勉強しないで遊びに行こうよとかね
それは味方ですね というわけで
我々の敵味方の区別もいい加減で曖昧なんです
一緒に一杯飲みましょうという人は友達で味方です
酒飲むなよと 体壊さないでいちゃとは
あれは敵ですね 次 コミュニケーションの問題
結構たくさんなりますから
早く飛ばさなくちゃいかんのです
味方の間でコミュニケーションが必要です
そこで味方の間でコミュニケーションしないと
あのニワトリは味方ですか？敵ですか
知ってますか？聞かない
ニワトリは味方ですよ
食べてるんだから ですから
チキンファームやっている人々は結構ニワトリのことを理解しようとしているんです
牛を飼っている人は 牛の気持ちも理解しようと
人間同士でも味方という人のことを理解しようとするんです
これは私が正しいという前提で生きている生命同士のコミュニケーションです
これで問題は 私には友達がいる
よく助けてくれる人で
助けてくれる人だから味方でしょ
そこで味方ですから その人とコミュニケーションをとってつなげていなくちゃいかんですね
で コミュニケーションを成り立たせるかというと
私は私が正しいと思っているし
その人はその人が正しいと思っているし
これでどこでコミュニケーションを成り立たすんですかね
稀にしか同意なんかは成り立たない
稀に同意があります 稀に
普通は同意は成り立ちません
夫婦喧嘩は？女には女の世界がありましてね
私は正しい 男には男の世界がありまして
私は正しいという そこでよくも一緒にいるんだからね
ぶつかりますよ コミュニケーション成り立たないんです
お母さんと子供の間でコミュニケーション成り立たないんです
お母さんはお母さんが正しいと思っているし
子供は子供が正しいと思っているんです
怒り 憎しみ 落ち込み 戦い
物分かり 悩み 誤解 批判
非難 侮辱などの世界が現れます
だからこの世界になるんです
我々は人間と付き合う時はこれですね
結果は怒りやら落ち込みやら憎しみやら
物分かりやら コミュニケーションが成り立たないからなんです
はい  3番目に行きますね
主観の本質 悩み苦しみ
主観を持つならば 他人との付き合いは正しく進まないんです
だから他人と付き合うことできません
主観を持っている限りは
しかし 人の理解とは主観なのです
精神の中で大混乱が現れます
心は戦場になります 主観を持つ限り
悩み苦しみはついてきます
セットです それはパッケージです
私は主観を持っている
皆様と喋ると 結構悩み苦しみが生まれるんです
ストレスが溜まってくるんです
どうしようもないんです
ということは 結論として言えば
主観を持つとは悩み苦しみのパッケージです
そこで自我の登場 感覚が生きるという実感を作ります
この肉体にある感覚 目
耳 鼻にある感覚で生きているという実感が生まれるんです
しかし 感覚が多数で無常です
感覚ってどういうふうに感覚として見ると
あるわあるわあるわあるわ
目の感覚をチェックしたっても
見る限り感覚が変わるんです
例えば皆様に舞台の方見えるんですね
スクリーンも見えるし
文字も見えるし この黒いカーテンもいろいろもの見えるでしょ
その分目の感覚が変わっているんです
だから区別で これはスクリーン
これは黒いカーテンであると
感覚変わっているんです
で 私に皆様一人一人別々な人間として見える
その分 私の目の感覚が多数なんです
瞬時に変わりますが 絶えず新たな感覚が生じます
感覚は瞬時に変わるんだけど
すぐ新しい感覚が生まれているんです
過去から起きて消えていった
多重多彩 多数の感覚を一つにまとめようとする感覚が自我という錯覚です
自我も感覚なんです 過去から現れてきた
もう数えられない 今も数えられない無数の感覚生まれてるんですね
多重多彩 多数なんです
感覚は膨大 これはまとめようという感覚が生まれるんです
一つに その感覚に自我というんです
それは錯覚です 自我は実際にあるものではなく
グループネームですね
感覚に付けているグループネームです
リンゴ ブドウ ミカン バナナなどに果物というような感じです
実際は果物はないんです
あるのはリンゴ ミカン
ブドウ あれやこれやでしょ
果物ってないんですからね
だからグループネームとしてあるんですね
すべての主観 感情 煩悩を自我というカバンにまとめます
それから自我というカバンを守ることになります
錯覚を作ってから感覚を自我というカバンに入れて
カバンを守ろうとするんです
だからミカンを守ろうとするんじゃなくて
果物を守ろうとしているんです
ブドウを守ろうとするんじゃなくて
果物を守ろうとするんです
そういうわけで 裸の王様が登場するんです
自我という自我とは決して高級ブランドのカバンではありません
実際しないので 裸の王様の世に一着しかない最高に美しい衣装なのです
ややこしい例えです この裸の王様の物語を思い出してください
王様は裸でしたけど 自分は世に存在しないものすごい美しい服
衣装を着ているんだと
この美しさは知識人にしかわかりませんよとかね
どうだいと威張ってるんです
本当は裸です だから我々は自我を持って威張っているんです
存在をしないんだ 自我は
錯覚です 過去からの感覚を一束にまとめただけなんです
人は他人の自我に気づきますが
自分の自我に気づけません
これは裸の王様と面白いことでしょ
裸の王様は裸ですよと気づいたのは子供なんですね
あんまり何の素直ですから
自我もないんだからね
だから大人たちは私には見えませんだけど
これ言ったらあかん それで私はバカやと思うんだからね
黙っていると 自我で 他の隣人も
例えば王様の大臣たちもね
服見えませんよ 王様は私には見えませんと言える？言えないんです
だって知識人ぶってますからね
その自我がなかった子供たちは
えっ 王様は裸やと指さしちゃったんです
あまりにも子供たち ガキたちが王様は裸やと
王様裸ですと言っちゃうところに
王様は仕方がなく戻る羽目になったんですね
我々はそれをやっているんです
例えば 私は自我張ってると自分ではわからないんです
他の人と あのね あんた自我張ってるんじゃない？これって気持ち悪くない？性格悪いでしょ
あなたはと他人が言うんです
自分では自我張っているとか頑固とか分かってないんです
だから完璧 裸の王様の物語はぴったし合うんです
この自我の問題には 自分の自我を守るんです
私たちは自分の自我を守る
そう 世間様は自我張るなよ
と言うんです はい 苦しみを脱却プログラムですね
という 要するに主観から脱却することなんですね
まず理解できる範囲を理解しましょう
他人を理解することは論理的に不可能です
理論的に不可能です 論理的ではなくてね
しかし 渇愛 貪瞋痴 自己愛
煩悩などは生命に共通です
煩悩はもう共通です 私の怒りを皆様に怒りも同じものなんです
自分の煩悩に合わせて
人の煩悩の世界をある程度で理解することはできます
例えば 私はかぼちゃが大好き
友達はりんごは大好き
私はりんごは嫌い 友達はかぼちゃが嫌い
しかし 大好きっていうところ
欲でしょ そこで私にちょっと無理するならば
私はかぼちゃを食べる時
感じる あの幸せ この人はリンゴを食べる時感じるでしょうというふうな感じで
煩悩の付き合いである程度で理解できる
学校でいじめられた経験があるお父さんに
自分の子供が学校でいじめられて落ち込んでいると
自分に当てはめてなんとかあの気持ちを理解できる
そこで落ち込みという落ち込みも怒りですね
で そこでなんとなくコミュニケーションが成り立つのです
煩悩が似ているものは仲良くします
それで面白いこと 我々は仲良くするでしょ
あれは煩悩が似ているんです
別に仲良いわけじゃないんです
例えば女性同士で もうブランドのもので体を飾っている方々は一つグループになっちゃうんです
煩悩の仲間なんです 男の場合もいろんな友達いるでしょ
あれは煩悩の仲間なんです
例えば 釣り好きな人がいる
毎日曜日釣りに行く そうすると他の釣りやってる人々はみんな仲間ですと
釣り仲間です ゴルフ仲間ですと言うでしょ
本当は仲間じゃなくて
ただ煩悩がちょっと似ているんです
子供は子供の世界を感じるが
母親の気持ちは理解することはできません
だから仲間以外はちょっと
子供って面白いですよ
子供同士ですごくお互い仲良く理解し合ってるんです
その子供を育てる母親の気持ちは理解しないのです
理解できないんです で
女は女の世界 男は男の世界を理解する
男女の理解は互いの関係の範囲に限ります
女は女の煩悩を持ってるんだから
他の女と大体スムーズに仲良くする
男たちも男たち同士で結構仲良くするっていう気がしますね
あれはもう男は男煩悩持ってますからね
だからその煩悩で仲良くするんです
それで男と女の付き合いはどうなるかというと
これ結構ややこしいんです
関係だけに限った仲良しなんです
コミュニケーションが成り立つために
何か共通する目的 好き嫌い
感情が必要です ですから
我々人間でコミュニケーションする場合は
共通する目的 人殺しましょうとかね
だってね イスラムの方々すごい仲がいいでしょ ISIS
のグループとか 残酷に殺してやりましょうとかね
そういう気持ちの人々はグループを作る
で 人のことを全面的に理解することは成り立たないんです
はい それから脱国の順番
ここは理解の世界ですね
理解絶対不可能ではなくて
煩悩が似ているならば
なんとかそこで仲良くする
自分の過ちに気づきません
当たり前なんです 自分の主観正しいんだからね
例えば 私が人を怒鳴ったとしましょう
私は正しいことをやっていると思っていますよ
怒鳴って何が悪いのかと
だってこの人はこれこれこれやったでしょうにと
と自分を正当化するんです
自分は正しいので当然です
しかし 他人の過ちなら派手に見えますね
あんた間違っていると
ですから 他人は何の躊躇もなく自分にアドバイスします
でしょう 世の中は それはみんなお説教ばっかしで
自分が聞きたくないしね
自分が正しいんだから
私は人を怒鳴ったら 私は当たり前と思ってるんですね
しかし 第三人者が来て
なんであんたあの人をそういう風に怒鳴るんですかと
怒鳴らなくてもいいんじゃないですかと
なんでそんな悪いことするのかと
第三人者が私にお説教するんですね
私は聞きたくない あんた何知ってるのかと
喧嘩を売るでしょ そこで自分の自我が割り込んで攻撃します
だから 親と子供の喧嘩も同じことです
子供はやりたいこと別にあって
お母さんが子供の気持ちは別なんですね
お母さんがこれやりなさいと言うんだけど
子供はこれやりますということで
そこでお互いちょっとぶつかっちゃいますね
我々は大人はもっと攻撃しますよ
何様のつもりですか？とかね
あんた何をわかって私のものを言うのかとかね
すごい狂暴な態度を取るんです
人に自分の過ちを見られるという現象を大事にしましょう
これで脱獄始まります
人にうるさくいろんなものを言われるでしょ
そこは大事にするんです
だって自分に見えませんから
私は小さい時からその性格でしたからね
小さい時から自分が正しいと頑固で思っていたんです
頑固で思っているんだけど
誰かがあのね これはと言ったら
あれ あ これやめなくちゃと思うんです
だから皆様も遅いんだけど
そうしてください これ小さい時からやらないと人格は向上しません
人に言われることはいいんです
人に言われた間違いが自分にあるか否かを観察しましょう
だから 例えば第三人者が私に
あのね なんであんたそんなきつい言葉でこの人怒鳴るんですかと
落ち着いたらどうですかと言われたら
あんた状況わかってる？って態度を取るんじゃなくて
この人はこういうことやったんだよと
ものを知らないで お説教するんだからといって攻撃してはいけません
それで私は自分でどうかなと
で 考えた方がいいでしょう
怒鳴って悪かったかと
言葉きつかったかと 怒鳴らないで
他の方法で これは言える方法なかったのかと
自分で自分の心を勉強するんです
それには人にものを言われていないとダメ
人は自分を批判してバカにしてもらわなくては困りますよ
だから あなたすごい あんたすごいというのは
みんなもうすごい危険な人間なんです
自分を何かに乗せをしているんです
あんた気持ち悪くて嫌な人間だと言った方がいいんです
その人は私を黙って何か取ろうともしていないし
正直に言うしね それで私はどうするかというと
自分を省みしたりする
こんな性格私にあるんですかねとかね
世界は無知なので気をつけます
だからといって人の言うことに何でも乗るんじゃないんです
なぜならば 世界はみんな無知です
みんな貪瞋痴です みんな主観で生きているんです
主観で生きているんだけど
たまたま私の過ちは見える可能性あります
だからそこら辺でも まあちゃんと区別して
乗るべき話に乗る  これは乗らなくてもいいっていうことにならないことにする
理性のある慈しみのある人の話を真剣に受け入れられます
そこでお釈迦様が推薦しているのは
相手に理性がある それから慈しみがある
それだったら話を聞きなさいと
いい例っていうのは母親ですね
母親は子供にだけ 慈しみがあるんですね
母親といってもそういうことじゃなくて
自分の子供だけですよ
普段はすごい恐ろしいですけど
で でも自分の子供は不幸になってほしくない
自分の子供は成功してほしい
だから 素直に母親が子供のことを心配しているんだから
子供たるものは母親の言葉を聞いた方がいいんです
母に逆らわない方がすごい無難です
まあ同じく父親もね そこで世の中で慈しみのある人
理性のある人 いうことを聞きなさいと
特にブッダの話を聞きなさいなんです
知恵は完成しているし
人格は完成しているし
悟りに達しているし 輪廻転生しないし
慈しみというよりも憐憫を持っているんです
人間が主観にはめられていかに苦しんでいるのかと
だからこうしなさい こうしなさい
こうしなさい こうしなさい教えるんです
次 性格改良 諏訪町という性格があります
他人のアドバイスにアドバイスに耳を傾ける柔軟性です
諏訪町というのは 教えやすい
アドバイスしやすい人間は成長します
いるでしょ いろいろ あ
この人ね 教えましょうとかね
そういう性格の人もいるんですよ
相手もニコッと ありがとうございます
教えてくれてとかいう風に素直に受け入れるんです
そうするとこちらもなんとなく教えてあげたいもんですね
その性格を育てなくちゃあかんです
あんた何様という態度を取ったら絶対自己破壊するんであって
成長はしません 時々子供にも自分の過ちを見ることがあるんです
世話長だったら聞きます
子供のくせにではないんです
自分が正しいという欠陥があることを素直に認めます
次に 皆様認めてないでしょ
素直に 無意識ではなくて
意識でも認めてください
私はいつでも私は正しいという態度で生きているんだよと
それを意識化してください
今は無意識にあるんですね
その気持ちは 本音にあるんですね
建前にしてください すぐ治ります
性格は 治るよりもものすごい楽な生き方が現れてくるんです
自分の意見を喋る時でも
ちゃんと遠慮して 相手が異論を立てても悩み苦しまないで
ああ そういう意見もあるんですねとかね
という風な なんかすごい優しい人間になっちゃうんです
方法は至って簡単 私が正しいというスタンスで生きているんだと
それは認めますと それだけ
次 自分の過ちを隠さない
見つかる次第に正す 努力する
過ちを犯したら隠すでしょう
あれ 自分が正しいんだからなんです
自分が正しいんだけど
表に言わない だから過ちを隠す
仏教では成長する人間が過ちは隠せないんだと素直に認めますと
それはすごい性格いいんですよ
なぜならば 人誰だって間違いを起こしますよ
基本的に誰も完璧じゃないんだから
私も過ちを犯すし 皆様方も過ちを犯すし
私は過ちをこれ隠そう
隠そう 隠そうと言っていい顔をしましょうと言ったら
なんだこりゃ 俺には過ちあるはずがないという態度なんですかね
過ちだらけだと それを認めて
あ 間違えました これは過ちですと認めれば至って簡単で
人生は 先輩たちのアドバイスを聞いてみる
日常生活の場合でも 先輩と経験ある人のアドバイスを聞いてみる
山を登りたければ まあ登った人がいるならば
ガイドさんがいるならば
その人のアドバイスも聞いてみる
教えられたことを真面目に実行する
それから私は過ちをすぐやるでしょ
それで誰かがこれを過ち
あ そうですね これは間違いで認めて
ではこうしましょうと言われたら
そこはちゃんとその通りにやる
4番目 脱国の順番で慈しむ
敵味方を作る 間違った見解を改良するのです
敵味方は存在しません
みんな生命です 一切の生命に対して慈しみを実践する
講演が始まる前にやった慈悲の瞑想ですね
生命はみんな同じだと
私も一人の生命で すべてはそれぞれの生命ですと
自我中心的に物事を見る癖がなくなります
それで結構自我中心的な物事を見る癖がなくなるのです
生命が敵だと見ることがなくなって
皆仲間だという気持ちになります
ものすごく楽になりますよ
みんな敵じゃなくて仲間ですよと
例えばゴキブリは敵でしょ
慈しむ それでゴキブリも仲間だと思ってみてください
楽しくなる 嫌な気持ちが生まれません
精神的に安らぎを感じます
そこで精神が今まで戦場状態でしょ
自我中心に生きているんだから
これは消えるんです 脱獄って難しいんですよ
順番があります 次 見解を改める
自分の意見に見解に 感情に
気持ちに固執することを戒めます
例えば私はなんていうのか
バナナが大好きやと これは私の個人的な見解なんですけど
あまり固執しない なんであんたことバナナ嫌いですかね？とかね
バナナって美味しいでしょうにと
あんた頭がおかしいと言っちゃったらダメでしょ
みんな自分の見解をむちゃくちゃ他人に押し付けようとする
それやめてほしい だから見解あるのは仕方がありません
固執する必要はないんです
他の人には他の意見がありますよと
私はバナナ大好きだって言ったって
バナナが大嫌いという人もいるんだよと
だからこれはただの習慣で仕方ありませんというといいでしょうに
楽でしょうに それが 客観的に物事を見るように励みます
だから 主観的ではなくて
客観的に見ようとするんです
主観があってもそれに固執しない
意見は主観であると認めて
落ち着いた生き方をします
で 例えば地球が丸いということは客観的なデータでしょ
全然問題ないんですね
我々は主観で困るんです
神がいるかいないかとかね
どんな政党を応援するかしないかとかね
それで困っちゃうんです
主観で困るんです 客観では何の困ることもないんです
6番目のステップは この自分を観察することですね
生きるとはどのような働きかと客観的に観察する
私も一部説明します 生きるということは大したことない
ただ感覚変化するだけ
感じることだけ だからこの感じることを調べれば
感覚から自我の錯覚が起こるのだと発見するんです
例えば痛みが生まれる
感覚でしょ すぐあ 痛いと私は入れているんですね
私はいい だけど だから痛みと感じるんです
寒気がする 寒いも自我が入ってるんです
そこでい 寒気を感じる
そこら辺で体で感覚が変化しているんだと
痛くなったら 例えば足でも腰でもいいんだけど
あ このところで違う感覚があるんだと
こちらで違う感覚があるんだ
痺れている あ こちら痺れという感覚がある
こちら痛みという感覚がある
こちらは痒みという感覚があると客観的に見ていくんです
そうすると 自我がないと見えてくるはずなんです
感覚は無常・苦・無我であると発見する
そうやって見ていると
感覚って生まれては消える
生まれては消える 生まれては消える
例えば音を聴いてみてください
音っていうのはすごい早く空気が耳に触れるでしょ
ものすごい波長が早いんですね
だから耳でこの感覚は生まれては消える
生まれては消える 生まれては消える
それを調べると この迷走する暇がないんです
だからすべて無常で実体がないで
なくて 空であるとわかるんです
執着に値するものは何もないという智慧が現れると
存在に対する執着が消える
今までバカなことをやっていたんだと発見するんです
存在に対する執着 あるいは自我に対する執着であってね
幻覚に対する執着なんです
それで脱却します 自分という殻が破れると主観もなくなるんです
主観がない人の意見は常に正見です
見解 邪見ではないんです
だから私たちにあるのは邪見です
見解です 自我の殻が破られたら正見ということになるんです
そこで主観ではないんです
すべての悩み 苦しみが消える
存在欲もなくなる 究極の自由と安らぎを経験する
自我の殻が破れてしまったら
主観も消えちゃって 正見になっちゃって
すごい なんかもう 言葉で言えない自由になるんです
だから  これは物質的な例えですけど
大宇宙があってね そこで自分という体を作っちゃうと
すごいちっぽけな存在でしょ
そこを破っちゃったらどうですかね
どれぐらい自由になるんですかね
はい 話のまとめというか
話はこれからいただきます
テーマまとめ え？私が悪い？その通りです
だから今日の講演テーマは一行で終わりましたからね
しかし それに気づくことは解脱への
自由への鍵です 私が悪いということに気づいてほしい
悪いという単語はあまり俗っぽい単語で
だから専門的に主観ということにしたんです
自我の錯覚が消えたら
私が悪い 私は正しい 相手が悪い
相手が正しい 世間が悪い
世間が正しいなどの束縛から抜け出します
束縛で束縛で もうあの人の言ってることは正しいんだけど
私が間違った あれって困るでしょ？私が正しいのになんであの人間違ってるのかって困るでしょ
そういう束縛で どちらでも束縛なんです
だから主観なくなったらもうそんな束縛何もないんです
一切の見解が消えます
無明がなくなります 智慧が現れます
終わりです  短いんですけど
質疑応答の時間を取りたいと思いますので
挙手していただけましたら
ちょっとマイクをお願いします
あ 今  意識の話のところで
体が壊れても意識は認識をして回転をしていくっていうのが
...推測で頭で考えると推測ではわかるんですが
それを私が生きているうちに自分で確認することはできないものなんでしょうか
とっても簡単にできます
例えば 我々はヴィパッサナー実践という方法を教えているんですよ
そう教えると みんなに言っているのは
ただ実況しながら歩きなさいと
実況しながら まあ座ったら体の感覚を感じなさいよと
それだけなんですけど
それは全然やらないで妄想ばっかりやってるんです
もう過去にしているんです
存在しないものを過去のこと
頭でぐるぐるぐるぐる頭ストップしないんですね
それがその法則あるんだから
この体が壊れても続けちゃうんです
で 体壊れる瞬間で 例えば死ぬ瞬間で意識は妄想し始めるんです
それが妄想かも 過去のことかも
だいたい過去のこと 何か思い浮かんじゃって
そちらにビッタシつなげるんです
それに合わせてもうつなげるんです
だからそれは瞑想するともうすぐわかることなんです
瞑想とかヴィパッサナー実践すると
意識は止まらないんだと
普通の俗世間的ににはもうこれちょっとわからないということになります
それもわかってます 俗世間の知識レベルではそんなのはわからないんです
はい  すいません 質問させていただきます
本日の講演で 男女の理解は互いの関係の範囲に限りますというお話だったんですけども
その男女の理解の関係の範囲を広げるためにはどうしたらよろしいんでしょうか
どういう人やろ  いや まあ個人的なお話なんですけども
私の彼女がタイ人でして
で もう付き合って3 4
年経つんですけども いや
どんどんどんどん関係が深くなってくるに従って
わからないこと 問題がやたら出てきてですね
はてどうしたものかと
うーん だからその人は違う文化の人だから
その人はタイ文化っていうものを持っている
だからあなたは あ これはタイの文化ですと
特にタイ人だったら仏教でしょう
だから仏教で言ったって結構わからないところいっぱい持ってるんです
はい  そういうところはまあ素直に聞いてみるとかね
だからあなたは主観ではなくて日本人でダメなんですね
だから客観的にこういうこと
どういうこと？と聞いてみて
そのまま理解しようとした方がいいんじゃないかなと思います
全てわからなくてもいいんです
うん それは私が分かろうとするんじゃなくて
客観的にどうかを  そうですね
そう考えれば できるだけ
あの範囲でわかるようになります
ありがとうございます
全部わかる必要はないんです
もう理論的にこれは不可能だからね
例えばあなたに子供が生まれましょう
子供のことは全部わかる
わかりませんよ そうですね
ですから それでわかる必要はないんです
関係の範囲で仲良くすればいいんです
わかりました ありがとうございます
はい  えーと まだ若干時間もございます
あ じゃあちょっとそちらの方によろしくお願いいたします
お話ありがとうございました
習慣を作る目的で それっていうのは存在欲と恐怖です
というところがあったんですが
個人としてもですね 何をするにもそのやっぱり恐れっていうのが付きまとってくるっていうところが自覚しておりまして
その恐れを手放すっていうところで
その瞬間瞬間にですね
ずっとその何をするにしても
人と対するにしても その場にいるにしても
何か恐れっていうものが元で
何かその相手を攻撃するような
自分を守るために何か攻撃してしまう
怒りを持ってしまう そういった心の内面っていうのが自分にもあるんですが
その恐れっていうのを手放すっていうことにおいて
ちょっとお話しいただければと思うんですが
それはあの 自分って何者かと
この自己観察では綺麗に消えますけど
それより先に慈しみを実践するんですよ
相手生命は敵ではなくて生命ですよ
だからみんな幸せで幸福でいてほしいと
その気持ち 自分で育てるんです
だからゴキブリやではなくて
生命ですと ゴキブリの生命体は自分で幸せでいたいんだから
じゃあ放っておきましょうよと
だから人間同士でも みんな一人一人の個人の生命であって
幸せに幸せで安穏でいた方がいいんじゃないかなっていう気持ちを育てるんです
それでもう恐れが消えちゃうんですよ
その気持ちを育てるということなんですが
一番初めに実践していただきました
その慈悲の瞑想っていうのが
やはり  そこデータを繰り返してくれて
脳にインプットするんですよ
それはインプットするたびに
脳の脳が成長しちゃって
生命は生命として理解することできるようになるんです
なるほど やっぱりその恐れっていうもので反応してしまうという癖っていうのが長年ついてますんで
それを改める 見方を変えるっていう意味では
そういった新たな習慣付けをするっていうことが重要っていうことですね
はいはいはい ありがとうございました
はい  えっと すいません
あの 他人を理解するのは
煩悩を通じて理解するんだって話があったと思うんですが
まあ仮にあの煩悩が減ってくると
逆にその他人が理解できなくなるっていうことがあるんでしょうか
それとも慈しみがこう間を埋めてくるっていうような感じになるんでしょうか
逆ですね 煩悩が減っていくと
どんどん人のことを理解できるようになるんです
煩悩があるんだから 自分の体
自分の色眼鏡で見ているんだからね
それはすりガラスの中を見ていることなんですね
だから煩悩がなくなった時に
すりガラスがなくなって透明のガラスになったっていうことなんですね
そうするとよく見えるんですね
だから煩悩があるんだから
我々のは他人のことを理解できないんですね
だから煩悩でコンタクトしているんですね
煩悩がなくなればなくなるほど
心落ち着いて おてあかりになっちゃって
人のことはよく理解できて
で この人はご飯食べたい
この人はラーメン食べたいっていうことはわかりませんだけど
生命として見えるんですね
だから理解広げるんです
わかりました で 理解しているのかどうかもよくわからないことが多いんですけども
それはこれ 超越した科学的な目で見なくちゃいけないんですね
だから この生命を超越した仏教科学で見るんです
そうするとみんな五蘊でできていて
心があってというシステムあるんですね
そこで見るんですね だから
そうするともう他 俗世間的なものはどんな関係ないんですよ
ラーメン食べたがってるか
ご飯食べたがってるかっていうところは
そんなに大きな問題じゃないんです
なるほど 命をそのまま理解できるんですね
なるほどです 俗世間は
でもまあ 世間的な断片でつながっているわけですけどね
世間では世間的な目的でつながっているわけです
ラーメンが好きだとか
そういうことで  だから会社の仲間が仲間でしょ
ある一つのところで一つの仕事をしているんだからでしょ
そうですね  はいはい そういう風に繋がっているのは
日本人は日本人として繋がっているしね
他の国の人々は外人と見ているしね
そういう風に見ているんですね
なるほど もう少しもう少し高いレベルっていうか
視点が違うわけですね
うん はい ありがとうございます
はい 瞑想をしてますとね
非常に怒りが自分は強いなって感じるんですね
自分の正しさと それからその怒りっていうのが抑えられないぐらい出てくるんですよ
それを瞑想中に気をつける方法っていうのはありますか？ あ
あの 怒りが出たら 素直にもう自分がものすごい怒りを作ってるんだとね
これはもう破壊の目的だと
これのせいで私は一向に幸福にならなかったと
まだやるのかと自分に厳しく叱るんです
またやるのかと どんなこと？これはもう自己破壊でみんなに迷惑でね
性格悪いんだと自分を戒めてみる
戒めてみてもいきなりは消えませんよ
どんどんどんどんゆっくりと減っていきますから
この長い間の癖だからね
だからそうやって叱ってみるんです
叱ってもまたやっちゃいますよ
またやっちゃったらまた叱ってみる
そこを繰り返っていくと
もうなんか怒らないでいることはどんどん減っていって
それから時々 いわゆる途中
ずっとではなく ポツンポツンと現れたりして
あ 怒り 怒りが起きたっていう風にそれはそれはできるんですね
自我の錯覚なくなるまでは怒りがあるんです
だから長い目で見てください
だから 解脱に達しない限りはもう習慣がありますから
もう煩悩はもうセットです
パッケージですからね
それでも悪性にならないように抑えることはできます
だからやり方は 怒りが出たら
まず怒り 怒りと 今怒りで燃えてるんだという風に確認する
それから自分を叱る この野郎とね
それも怒りですけどね
なんで情けないかと 瞑想をしているんではなくて
怒りを育ててるんではないかと
これはけしからんのだと
これいいことは何もないでしょうと叱って
また続けるんです 自分の瞑想
ちょびっと叱るだけ そういうふうにやってみてください
ありがとうございました
制限がありまして まず私と一緒に唱えましょう
ドゥッカパッタチェーニン
ドゥンカーバヤンパンターチェーニンバヤ
ソーカンパッターチェーニスソーカーホントサンビーピーパーリヌ
日本語の苦しむものの苦しみがなくなりますように
怯えるものの怯えが消えますように
悲しむものの悲しみがなくなりますように
一切の生命がかくのごとくありますように
はい どうもありがとうございます
サッビートゥワジャンツーサッブローゴーヒナッセットーマーティーバワットアンドラヨースキーディーガイコバワバウトサッブマンガランラッカントサンバデーヴァタ
サッブブッダヌバーヴェーナサッブダンマーナバーヴェーナサッブサ
カーンバーヘン サダ スッティ
バワン トゥティ アビ バーダナ
シーリッス ニッチャン
バッダ バチャイノ チャッタロー
ダンマ バッダム ティー
アイ ワンノ スカン バラン
サードゥ サードゥ サードゥ
それではスマナサーラ先生
ありがとうございました
皆様も長い時間お疲れ様でした